thanks for watching
that's our show
James Corden bids farewell to The Late
Late Show I'm gonna miss going into work
every day and seeing what silly things
we can come up with I'll forever be
proud of it on Thursday James hosted his
last episode of The Late Night show full
of celebrity guests and surprises even
President Joe Biden sent James a message
1200 shows in eight years but after the
day spent working for me at the White
House I'm surprised it lasted eight
years in Asia yeah the UK native paid
the prez a visit last year filling in
for potus's assistant and let's just say
it was chaotic you're a big fan of the
the aviators I'm just wondering
whether you might want to mix it up a
little bit I mean I think if you came
out a couple of ice creams I'm worried
about you I can't wait to see what you
do next meanwhile several other late
night hosts Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel
Seth Meyers and Stephen Colbert as well
as Late Show Alum David Letterman joined
James for a sketch warning him not to
quit posting the network late night talk
show makes you part of a very exclusive
club and if we're going to let you leave
we need to know you'll keep our sacred
Secrets James said he remembered moving
to America and hearing about the late
night Wars but explained they're
actually a family I haven't felt this
scared
since I decided to take the show and
move
to America to do it I'll miss it I'll
miss it every day as for his final
guests on the show Harry Styles and Will
Ferrell stop by and destroyed his desk
with a sledgehammer
[Applause]
and Harry reminisced on his past
appearances on the show like the time he
got a tattoo during his One Direction
days
reveal the tattoo now here it is
there it is
oh my goodness
he has the words late late tattooed on
his arm yes I'm so incredibly proud of
you Harry it's just a a dear friend he
was like I am coming on your last show
and in a more serious moment James
thanked the crew of his show and spoke
directly to his audience I've watched
America change a lot I've watched
divisions grow and I guess all I really
want to say tonight is I implore you to
remember what America signifies to the
rest of the world so what's next for
James here's what he told E.T I'm gonna
have to spend a bit of time and not rush
into to doing anything else I just want
to focus on just my family and kids and
resettling them and all the things that
are going to come with such a big shift
every single day I'll miss it thank you
for allowing me into your home every
night
[Music]